thank you for introducing me so today
I'm going to talk about fighting throats
fighting fraud finding duplicated skill
first a few words about me
originally I come from software
engineering like my original background
in software engineering I worked for a
couple of years as a Java developer then
I decided to switch into data science I
did a master's in business intelligence
last year was in Berlin and I decided to
stay in Berlin and since 2015
I've been working this data scientist
full-time first time I got into this
problem of duplicates was a cattle
competition
a few years ago organon organized by a
veto a veto is a largest classifieds
website in Russia so they had this
problem of duplicates and then they
asked the community to help them to
detect duplicates using machine learning
I did pretty well in that competition
since then many people found me many
companies found me on the leader board
contacted me asking for help I did help
a couple of companies so I want to
summarize all this experience and
reasons here and also the talk today
will be not about how to do well in a
Cargill competition like this but rather
what are the next steps
ok now you did well on cargo what is
next how to use this so that's me one
year ago so this logo there is oleg
scoop and alex group probably many
people here who are from germany didn't
hear about this this is actually quite
large company like this is a parent bred
for many classifieds websites so ivt is
one of them i already mentioned they
hosted that competition on cargo so this
is the largest classifieds in Russia
then oil leaks itself is classified
website in a bunch of countries like in
many countries like Poland Ukraine India
Kazakhstan
quite a lot of countries and let go is
also third big brand underlings group
this is large classifieds mobile in the
states so today I'm not going to talk
about specifics of the system that we
have a telex but rather about the
general approach I want to start to
start the presentation by talking about
user-generated content so user-generated
content is content generated by users so
there is a website can be a blog post
can be a social network can be a
classifieds website where users can post
content so user can go come to this
website and create a post about the doc
and then write something this dog is so
nice then they can get carried away like
they love this dog so much or if it's a
classifieds website maybe they want to
solve this dog so they can complete
multiple listings and basically span the
platform or they can post something not
appropriate on the platform or maybe
something illegal in case of classified
they want they might try to sell
something that they are not supposed to
so there is a bunch of problems with
user-generated content especially fraud
and duplicates so these two things
frozen duplicate see often come hand by
hand they are not always related but
often they are and typically it happens
like this so somebody goes to the
platform for example as files and one to
sense wants to sell something the dock
another fraudster comes the fraudster
copies the picture and waits till there
disappears and then they post another
listing with the same image maybe with a
better description and better price and
then somebody comes to the platform okay
nice dog I want to buy it they call the
seller and the seller says yeah you know
there are like ten people in front of
you in the queue they all want to get
this dog but if you give me hundred
dollars I will reserve it for you
and he gets money and disappears and the
buyer is very unhappy and frustrated so
how can we help them how can we prevent
it instead of just letting users publish
everything they want we should first
look at what is there and decide whether
it should be allowed to not for that
there are contamination systems they
might look like this so user post
something and then there is automatic
moderation system that looks at this and
uses machine learning to decide is it
suspicious or not and then they can
reject it right away saying okay this is
not allowed they can accept it saying
it's fine or in many cases when
situation is locked here we can ask
people sorry to you to ask
so moderators are actual people who have
some kind of interface to look at these
items from the queue and decide to make
the final decision whether it should go
lie upon the platform not this automatic
moderation system may contain or
multiple components like a system for
detecting explicit content a system for
detecting forbidden items and a system
for detecting duplicates so this is what
I'm going to cover today I already give
gave a talk about duplicates so that
talk here you can follow it like there
is a link it's more about methodology
like how to do well on akikko
competition so this talk as I mentioned
is slightly different it's about the
system but still there is a lot of
useful information there so you can have
a look in somebody how to approach this
problem so it's a two-step problem so
you can approach it with two steps first
step is you select candidates something
that is not necessarily duplicates but
could be duplicates and ways to do this
is ok you have a knot what are the other
ads published in the same category or
what are the other ads published in the
same city what are the other ads
published by the same server what are
the other ads published from the same IP
from the
device so this is not necessarily
duplicates but there is very high chance
that they could can be duplicates and
then on the second step from all these
candidates who actually use machine
learning to find what are the real
duplicates there and what we do is we
get all these candidates from the
previous step and then we ask people to
look at them and say okay is it
duplicate or not so people say duplicate
or not and we get this training data
which consists of a pair I D 1 and D 2
and label 1 if it's duplicate label 0 0
it is not a duplicate and then we can
compute all kind of features from this
then throw it into a machine learning
model and then this model will tell us
will actually help us find the goodies
features can be pretty simple like ok
what is the absolute price difference
what is the relative price difference is
it published from the same ip what is
the distance between these two listings
same location is it same category we can
also look at similarity between two
titles ok are these two titles similar
are these two titles different basically
these are all features that we will use
in the model it's quite important when
we have images like in classifieds case
to look at them as well because an image
is worth 1000 words and especially in
classifieds buyers want to look at the
item before deciding ok do it do I want
it or not with images hashes are a very
useful thing because they summarize the
entire image into a simple bytes thing
that we can use for comparison there are
multiple types of caches first category
of caches is cryptographic hashes so
this is our general-purpose coaches like
md5 that are needed to do detective file
was modified a lot for example in case
of md5 if we take a file and change just
one bit of this file it will result in a
completely different and if I - these
hashes are useful in duplicates but only
to detect byte by byte
exact matches listen
there are other kind of questions
they're called perceptive caches so
these caches when you change only if you
open the image and change only one pixel
with Microsoft Paint or whatever paint
and save it it should result in the same
cache so in this example so we changed
image slightly that resulted in a
completely different in the fire - that
we have on the bottom but the hash which
is a perceptive fresh stayed the same
and there are many versions like this so
the way it worked they work I will not
go into the code I'll just explain how
they work this is D hash so we have an
image we then break it in multiple cells
and then for each cell we calculate the
average pixel value layer and we see
that for the area where the image was
modified the value is different the rest
is the same what we do next is we
compute the difference between second
column and first third column and the
second and so on so we'll have this
bunch of differences and then finally we
just consider if it's greater or zero or
not so we have a bunch of boolean
variables by and then we can think okay
we have this blue boolean array let's
treat this as bits and compress it into
one digit like each rows each row of one
bit becomes eight bits sorry becomes one
byte image one byte integer sorry and
then we can basically represent each
integer as a hash put them together as a
hex put them together and get a hash
other hashes are the perceptive hashes
work quite similar to this and then this
caches since they are perceptive so they
have this nice property that small
modifications in input lead to small
modifications are an output we can use
them to compare two images we can just
look at how many bits are different and
that will tell us how different these
images are this is quite useful feature
but what is war we can use these hashes
to actually select candidates we can say
okay
what are there all other listings that
have the same image and that will give
us a lot more indie days to consider we
can go deeper and include also use
neural nets and like in any
convolutional neural net we have this
layer before the final prediction
usually called fully connected there and
this is typically used to extract
so-called image embedding so this is
like a vector representation of an image
so we have a mean image and it gives us
an umpire array that represent this
image they have nice semantic properties
that two similar images have very
similar vectors so this is an official
example from Charis it's pretty easy
just like ten lines of code that give us
this representation this example however
uses vgg which is quite heavy it's like
half a gig model typically like it's not
worth it they're slow
they heavy there are lighter models like
mobile net that I don't know like 25
times smaller and they have similar
accuracy and the embeddings that we get
from a bio net are similar to have
similar properties so it's better to use
them just like again the code is pretty
simple so okay we get mobile net we
extract features but this gives us quite
a large quite large vectors so in this
case it's more than thousand what do we
do with this next what we can do is take
this large vector and use simple
dimensionality reduction techniques like
singular value decomposition or PCA to
reduce it to something more manageable
like a hundred dimensions but then from
that we still want to compute caches
because caches are nice easy to deal
with and for that we use our sh oh Sh is
locality sensitive fashion this is a
family of hash
a perceptive cache that we covered
previously is also Sh because they have
this nice property that a small change
in input results in a small change in
output so just an idea or one of the
hashes of Sh
it's called random projection they are
built on this idea that if something is
closed in the original space when we
project it stays still closed if
something is far when we project this
far so we just generate random vectors
if we project them down in this case two
cars are still close or two animals are
close hmm and then we can generate many
such vectors and project on them so this
is the basic idea of random projects so
it's very easy to implement so we
generate many projection vectors store
them somewhere store them somewhere we
do it only once and then for each image
for each vector that we have we use
these projection vectors to calculate
hashes and then we store them somewhere
where to store of course the elastic
search so why elastic search elastic
search is implementation it uses Lucene
to implement inverted index inverted
index so like in case of direct index is
when by ID and direct index is when from
ID we can get a document so like for
example we have image 81 and we use it
to get the actual image but inverted
index is the other way around
we can ask okay for this hash what are
the images and this is exactly what we
need for this problem because we want to
find all other listings that have the
same image that has the same hash so we
can just throw everything into a stick
search and it will give us the answers
I can also go through the inn and
instead of just using the exact match we
can chunk the cash into four or five
chunks and then say tell elasticsearch
okay this is the usual stink treat it as
a usual string because elasticsearch is
a system for text search that can build
on top of that saying okay three two the
string as usual talking says words and
then look for this and then when we do
this when we search using such queries
and then first it will find exact
matches then matches where three out of
four tokens match then might just want
to out of four tokens match we can index
everything like every income in every
item that we have we can index in
elastic search and to find duplicates we
can use more likely these queries saying
hey I have this document with this a B I
want to find all the other documents
that are similar to this and then we
don't just use hashes we can put title
description all the text all fields and
say okay I want like using elastic
search we can also say I want title to
be two times more important than other
fields so this is very useful and we can
use these to get candidates so how to
actually do this now we have this idea
that we have hashes how do we put them
to elastic search what is the big
picture we can build a system for
indexing everything so a user creates
listing and this listing is stored
somewhere image can go to a three as
three is storage from AWS where we can
keep files so image gets to s3 then
every time you put something to s3 has
three genius an event saying hey
something was put to this bucket so this
is the bucket name and this is the name
of the file that was put there then a
lambda function a double as lambda
function and listen to this events
coming from s3 and okay there is a new
file
let's fetch it and calculate some hashes
so with just these four lines of code we
can already compute all these caches
there is library for that image hash
it's simple as as simple as that then we
put all these caches to another queue
and then eventually go still a sick
search so it looks like this so why do
we need an extra step from lambda to
elasticsearch not directly because in
case there is a peak who don't want to
kill elasticsearch with many inserts so
we want to place it out that's why we
have a separate component in between and
lambda really scales so it really takes
all our way all this complexity of
scaling up and down and in Peaks like
when we have for example 200 indications
per second it just scales there is
nothing to worry about and there is no
invocation Goes Down course and we can
process this way like 10 million images
per layer of course we don't always just
insert into elasticsearch we can we also
need sometimes to delete things
similarly we can subscribe to delete
events from s3 and also have another
component that updates records in
elastic search saying hey this thing was
removed from from our search also
colored neural networks we can add an
extra flaw that covers them as well so
we can have a flow parallel to these
they takes care of like it again
features images but instead of computing
just hashes it applies a neural network
and then compute so let's say a user
selects H to compute occasions so the
reason it's separated because the load
is quite different in case of hashes
it's quite light but convolutional
neural network is more like it's heavier
that's why it's a good idea to separate
them how to actually how do you actually
create this component where do we host
it one of the options is again AWS
lambda it's tricky because if we use
tensor flow then the flow binaries are
super big
and it's tricky to create a lambda
function that space within a WS limits
because the limit is like 50 megabytes
compressed but tensorflow is just too
big it's still possible to do it and
compress after a few days of painful
work it's still possible and if the Lord
is not high it's totally worth it
because we can score 1 million images
with just 60 bucks however when the load
is like ten millions images per day it
becomes expensive it's like six hundred
per day so better option is actually
used easy to machines from AWS or
kubernetes so these machines are always
up because if there are and for this
reason if it's just not so many images
it's more expensive because all these
machines are an idle but in case the
load is high and there is always
something it becomes cheaper and it will
cost like six hundred for example for
entire month instead of just one day
this is like for high load like the
multiple million images per day
kubernetes is probably a better choice
and then finally the big picture looks
like this so user upload something and
then the content and images go through
this indexing process and then by the
time the content reaches the automatic
validation system it's already indexed
and well then we can talk the duplicated
ask the duplicate detection system Hey
like what are the other duplicates what
are the other duplicate candidates what
are the other duplicates in case one we
are certain we can right we reject these
items in case when we are not we can ask
moderators to reject and actually use
the output from moderators the feedback
they give to have a better model so
because
all right thanks very much questions
anybody
the only mic hi do you have any
mechanism to guard against false
negatives missed in the initial
candidate section yeah it's pretty
difficult yeah so like you have to like
you can include a lot more than you like
there is a trade-off
like how much computational power you
want to invest into doing this of course
you can have your candidate set very
large then you have to process a lot of
things so depending how costly is the
mistake of letting the duplicate slip
through yeah so there is no other way
just trying to score as much as possible
it's pretty like it's a very difficult
problem
yeah thank you very talk very
interesting my question would be isn't
this also wrong for a text I mean do you
know of any like Ellis age Justins
maximization that takes what anything
like that no so for example like if
somebody takes an image and takes a crop
from this image then hashes we've
already stopped working with oh Sh it's
like they are more resilient but again
of course there will be cases when what
you can find an angle for which you're
at eight and then neural network becomes
like it doesn't matter sit for that we
can train CME's networks so try to do
all this like a tation and all this
manipulation with images and train and
you don't let to recognize these
rotations then the hashes will be not
just general purpose like not just from
the general-purpose network but
something you specifically train for
this particular program so this is the
good next step after just using the
petain model they actually have a
special neural net that
output caches thank you for the talk I
have one question concerning the images
because usually the websites are
optimizing the images and they are
heavily you can be heavily modified if
they are uploaded several times like
download link and upload again how
resistant are the hash is to to that so
if you just take an image open it in any
editor and save it with a different
compression hashes should still stay the
same if you change small area hashes
should still stay the same if you add a
logo like a watermark some of the hashes
will still say the same depending on the
size of this logo but when you start
cropping parts of image or rotating
image or flipping it somehow
then hashes will stop working but for
these simple things like the compression
they will stay the same one question the
output of the CNN why do you a [ __ ]
can't you just like put it directly into
elasticsearch I don't know a simple way
to do this to actually to also be able
to handle all these loads
because I can imagine that you insert
you need to insert like 10 million
images per day to this index and then
like you want to reduce your sessions in
search space as much as possible so with
this load it's kind of difficult there
are other things like things like files
or unloyal
that work directly on these row vectors
but with higher load they become very
slow and tight to be honest I don't know
a nice way to put these vectors like
real vectors to elasticsearch so hash is
the simplest way any other questions
no then let's thank the speaker again
[Applause]